chances are you've probably heard of
Imran Khan at 70 years old he is
Pakistan's current most well-known
personality the cricketer turned
politician has a special appeal among
the youth but he's also popular among
all age groups and social classes but
the meteoric rise in his appeal is not
just down to his personality and
background
with millions of followers across major
social networks the profile of Imran
Khan and his party dwarfs that of other
politicians in Pakistan and it's not
just the number of followers it's
carefully targeted messaging that helps
give Han The Edge Imran Khan basically
Imran Khan is an excellent Market here
he tries to appeal to every class of the
society by leaving everything open-ended
people fill in the blanks according to
their own biases my Khan is another
version of your Han Poor People's Khan
is different from the rich clerics is
different and he has a separate appeal
for liberals there is no definitive
ideology behind him Dr Farhan work used
to run social media accounts for Imran
Khan's party as himself a woman and many
other fake identities to prove his point
about contradictions he told us to look
at Imran Khan's statements made during a
recent court case it's not the security
agency it's one man the Army Chief I
have repeatedly sent him these messages
not now ever since he's been
I said look I know your fear is that if
I come to power I will remove
denotify you as The Amity I promise I
won't do it you say that the problem is
with the Army chief but you also say
that you promise that you will not sack
him so which one is it all I'm saying is
the problem is not from my side it's
from the other side his critics accused
the powerful military of engineering him
into Power silencing critics and forcing
the media to only air The Narrative of
his Pakistan Teri kinsaf or PTI party
Han says that's a myth Imran Khan's
cricket and fame philanthropic projects
and a revamp religious appeal all
contributed to where he is now but he is
also a part of a culture where people
gravitate towards strong personalities
our mind is personality driven even if
you look around the world its
personalities that matter for people
they have sentimental connections and
sometimes they even follow them blindly
there's a trust Factor as well with
people who portray themselves as saviors
in that psychological relationship isn't
easily swayed despite criticism that Han
has failed to fulfill campaign promises
made many policy u-turns as well as him
facing charges of corruption and misuse
of power it seems to have little impact
on his followers many analysts have
questioned why Imran Khan changes his
messaging his former party members say
that's a strategy which appears to every
segment of society and as long as Imran
Khan's PR tactics work they say his
message will continue to resonate among
all of his different supporters